j'informe l'assemblée que la présidente
a pris acte du dépôt d'une motion de
censure en application de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution par Madame
Mathilde Panau monsieur André chassegne
madame cyiel châelin monsieur Boris
valallot et 143 de leurs collègues le
1er décembre 2023 à 18h05 la première
ministre ayant engagé la responsabilité
du Gouvernement sur l'adoption en
lecture définitive du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 en conséquence ordre du jour
appelle la discussion et le vote sur
cette motion de censure la parole est à
Madame ségolen amion pour le groupe la
France
insoumise
bonjour
merci Madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons à nouveau
pour voter une motion de censure nous
nous retrouvons à nouveau pour dénoncer
l'usage excessif antidémocratique et
bayonnant du 493 le 2e
493 nous députés de la France insoumise
refusons de rendre acceptable dans une
démocratie cette pratique qui vise à
réduire au silence les élus représentant
du peuple et donc le peuple
lui-même par ces 493 successifs non
seulement vous refusez d'écouter les
représentants du peuple mais vous privez
aussi les Françaises et les Français du
débat public qu'il
mérite si vous n'y entendez rien madame
la Première ministre moi je vous ai
écouté je vous ai entendu vous plaindre
de la lenteur de l'examen du PLF SS
c'est vrai examiner un budget de 640
milliards d'euros ça devra ça devrait
être bouclé en 3 4 heures à vue de nez
mais laissez-moi vous me plaindre à mon
tour de la lenteur avec laquelle vous
intégrez la notion de
coconstruction celle que vous invoquez à
chacun de vos discours à chaque fois que
vous engagez la responsabilité de votre
gouvernement et alors non ça ne veut pas
dire c'est moi qui décide et c'est comme
ça ça ne veut pas dire non plus que vous
pouvez vous nous nous envoyer votre
budget le lundi en espérant que nous le
signerions le mardi sans y apporter la
moindre
modification d'ailleurs ce que vous avez
appelé la dénaturation de votre budget
s'appelle en réalité démocratie
parlementaire et non le principe de la
coconstruction c'est un travail concerté
avec l'ensemble des forces en présence y
compris les vôtres qui je vous en
informe sont aussi en colère de ne pas
pouvoir participer non plus un travail
concerté donc dans lequel chacune et
chacun fait des compromis voire des
concessions compromis c'est l'autre mot
que vous prononcez à chacun de vos
discours encore un mot creux que vous
n'utilisez que pour vous que pour cacher
le fait que vous n'appliquez pas le
concept et cette fois encore en
engageant la responsabilité de votre
gouvernement vous avez agité le chiffon
rouge du déficit public pour mieux
justifier les coupes budgétaires les
économies et les défauts
d'investissement mais vous oubliez de
dire que vous avez rejeté des
amendements représentant des milliards
d'euros de recettes qui permettrai
d'appliquer une toute autre politique
une politique de gouvernance par les
besoins par
exemple et
attention pas les envies des minorités
les plus riches mais les besoins du plus
grand nombre vous avez par exemple passé
sous le silence les 8 milliards d'euros
du président cqurel pour soutenir les
centres médicaux de santé des communes
sous silence encore la transparence sur
les prix des
médicaments encore une fois et même si
cela vous fait rire vous faites encore
croire que sans votre budget et
uniquement votre budget la totalité de
nos institutions et de nos
fonctionnaires ne seraiit plus payé
mensonge mensonge et quelle suffisance
quelle suffisance faut-il pour croire
non seulement une fois mais deux années
de suite que vous seul êtes absolument
dans le vrai que vous ne faites aucune
erreur que votre gouvernance est
absolument parfaite quel mépris quel
prix faut-il pour rester sourd au CR
d'alarme des parents qui n'ayant pas eu
de place en pédopsychiatrie pleurent
leurs
enfants quelle suffisance faut-il pour
être sourd au mère qui accouche sur le
bord des autoroutes faute de maternités
ouvertes et ça vous fait rire
sérieusement sérieusement ça vous fait
rire ben justement un peu de sérieux
écoutez-moi plutôt que d'en
rire quelle suffisance faut-il pour ne
pas entendre ces femmes qui perdent des
chances de survie en attendant presque
un an pour une mammographie aux enfants
dont les parents sont en épad sous-dotés
au soignantes et au soignants qui disent
ne pas avoir les moyens de prendre soin
et pire qui avoue en pleurant qu'ils en
deviennent
maltraitants à quel point faut-il être
aveugle pour ne pas voir que votre
politique accentue la pauvreté accentue
les inégalités et fait monter la colère
qui pousse à trouver un coupable
cette colère qui pousse à la haine de
l'autre cette haine de l'autre
meurtrière qui est le lit de l'extrême
droite j'ai honte j'ai honte de notre
démocratie malade que vous poussez un
peu plus vers l'autoritarisme à chaque
493 j'ai honte de vous entendre dire
qu'on ne peut pas priver les concitoyens
des services publics dont ils ont
cruellement besoin alors même que votre
politique les détruit j'ai honte de vous
entendre avouer que vous ne cherchez
même pas à coconstruire à l'avenir
puisque et là je vous cite vous estimez
qu'il n'existe aucune majorité capable
de s'entendre autour d'un budget
mesdames et messieurs madame born a nous
a informé que ce sont bien 3 ans et demi
de 493 qui nous attendent mais madame
borne ce n'est pas le contrat
républicain
collègu combien de 493 encore combien de
consultations citoyennes sans suite
combien d'assises fantoche combien
d'invitations à l'Élysée combien de
consultations de cabinet de conseil avec
des millions d'argent public combien de
promesses en l'air vous vous faudra-t-il
encore pour vous rendre compte que le
président et son gouvernement font tout
pour contourner ce Parlement et
contourner la démocratie et comment en
tant que député pouvons-nous nous en
satisfaire alors puisque ce gouvernement
nous le dit nous l'avoue qu'il n'existe
aucune majorité capable de s'entendre
autour de son budget nous nous nous
sommes donc en devoir de changer ce
gouvernement en votant cette motion de
censure je vous
remercie merci Madame
Amot la parole est à Monsieur Yannick
nouder pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la présidente Madame la première
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous voici
donc sans surprise dans cet hémicycle
pour examiner une 1è motion de sensure
suite à un éem 493 sur le PLFSS 2024 un
rendez-vous habituel mais aujourd'hui le
dernier rendez-vous puisque le PLFSS
pour 2024 est considéré comme
définitivement adopté je ne reviendrai
donc pas sur les revendications du
Parlement face face au 493 mais
permettez-moi plutôt d'attirer votre
attention sur trois enjeux majeurs
concernant la santé de nos
concitoyens tout d'abord j'aimerais vous
parler de la santé mentale et de la
psychiatrie en France laquelle est dans
une situation alarmante pourtant cette
situation devrait tous nous
interpellerer n'oublions pas qu'un
Français sur trois souffrira de troubles
mentaux à un moment de sa vie malgré
cela depuis la rentrée 2023 la crise
dans le secteur de la santé mentale
s'aggrave un peu partout en France
notamment avec des patients non pris en
charge ou pris en charge tardivement
d'ailleurs près de 2 ans après les
assises de la psychiatrie le secteur de
la santé mentale est toujours en état
d'urgence madame la Première ministre le
ne de la psychiatrie manque de moyens
cruellement c'est le parent pauvre de
nos politiques publiques en matière de
santé souvenez-vous de l'infirmière tuée
à reins elle n'est pas seulement morte
sous les coups de son agresseur mais
aussi sous les décombres de la
psychiatrie française qui faute de
moyens laisse des patients dangereux en
liberté pourtant les rapports
d'information ne manquent pas tout comme
les donniers publics puisque que la
psychiatrie demeure le premier poste de
dépenses en matière de santé 14,5 % de
la facture de la facture annuelle soit
23,4 milliards d'euros pour l'assurance
maladie alors comment expliquer ce
paradoxe c'est le constat le constat est
bel et bien le suivant la psychiatrie
est en crise mise à mal par les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire et
par plus de 30 % de postes non pourvus
dans les hôpitaux publics selon les
données de la Fédération Française de
Psychiatrie je sais les efforts mis en
place de depuis plusieurs années mais
qui ne valent rien face à un grand plan
de la psychiatrie car notre ambition
pour la psychiatrie en France doit être
triple d'abord promouvoir le bien-être
mental et réparer et repérer plus
facilement les situations de souffrance
psychique ensuite garantir une offre de
soins accessible et divers diversifié en
psychiatrie et enfin améliorer
l'insertion des personnes en situation
de handicap mentale permet permettez-moi
aussi de revenir sur le dispositif mon
parcours psy misise en place suis aux
assises de la psychiatrie si le
dispositif vise à améliorer l'accès aux
soins en santé mentale pour lutter
contre les inégalités en santé il est
boycotté par de nombreux psychologues 1
an après son lancement ce dispositif
enregistre seulement 2200 psychologues
volontaires conventionnés soit 7 % des
psychologues libéraux et une moyenne de
4,1 séances par patient les praticiens
dénoncent le plafonnement du prix des
séances très inférieur au prix
couramment pratiqué et les découragent à
se conventionner
de plus le nombre de séances remboursé
fixé au nombre de 8 n'est pas toujours
suffisant pour pour assurer le suivi
dans son intégralité et tant à créer une
rupture de soins pour les patients les
plus précaires qui ne pourront pas
suivre leurs séances il est désormais de
votre responsabilité de faire évoluer ce
dispositif enfin quand j'entends madame
la Première ministre le ministre de
l'Intérieur demander une injonction de
soins suite à l'attaque de ce weekend
j'espère que nous avons les moyens d'y
répondre mais j'en doute le deuxème
point madame la Première ministre que je
souhaite évoquer devant vous concerne
les addictions responsables de la perte
annuelle de 130000 vies humaines en
France par an laquelle s'ajoute des
coûts sanitaires et sociaux
considérables la dépense directe des
finances publiques s'élève à plus de 22
milliards d'euros soit 1 % du PIB le
niveau élevé d'usage de substance à
l'âge adulte dans la population
française s'explique par un début très
précoce dans leur consommation c'est
pourquoi la consommation de drogue
d'alcool et de tabac par les adolescents
constitue un problème de santé publique
majeur auxquel il faut apporter des
réponses prioritaires et croyez-moi la
situation chez les jeunes est alarmante
à titre desemple à titre d'exemple
pardon pour les boissons alcoolisées une
enquête réalisée en 2022 chez les jeunes
de 17 ans révèle que 37 % d'entre eux
ont déjà vécu une alcoolisation
ponctuelle importante c'est-à-dire siiv
ou plus en une seule occasion cette même
enquête montre par ailleurs une grande
htirogénicité dans les comportements
selon la situation des jeunes par
exemple les jeunes en apprentissage ou
sortie du système scolaire ont des
niveaux d'usage de drogue licite ou
illicite nettement supérieurs en
comparaison des élèves scolarisés dans
le secondaire mais au-delà d'un enjeu de
santé publique majeur la consommation de
drogue chez les jeunes révèle des enjeux
sociaux encore plus grands l'Académie
nationale de médecine elle-même rappelle
la vulnérabilité extrême de de
l'adolescent aux addictions qui justifie
des actions particulièrement fortes en
matière d'information et en matière de
prévention c'est donc au pouvoir de ce
public de se saisir de cette question
des afin d'en limiter les conséquences
chez les jeunes toutefois force est de
constater que nous sommes de très
mauvais élèves en terme d'éducation à la
santé afin d'informer et de prévenir les
dangers inhérents à la consommation de
drogue et au risque d'addiction à cette
fin il faudrait par exemple créer des
programmes éducatifs à la santé
obligatoire dès l'école primaire jusqu'à
l'université ou encore assurer une
formation efficace des enseignants en
charge de ces actions en lien avec les
acteurs du médico-social et les
autorités compé
enfin ça sera mon dernier point je
souhaiterais attirer votre attention sur
la situation financière insuffisante des
soins palliatifs en France et ce à
l'aube d'une éventuelle légalisation de
l'euthanasie d'après la Cour des comptes
les besoins estimés de soins palliatifs
ne seraient couvert qu'à 48 % alors même
que le droit d'accès aux soins
palliatifs suppose une couverture de la
totalité des besoins la dépenses publiqu
des soins palliatifs étant de 1,5
milliards d'euros en 2021 une simple
extrap tion arithmétique permettrait
d'estimer les besoins de financement à
1,6 milliards quand on sait que ces 80
millions qui ont été proposé dans ce
PLFSS il faudra à ce rythme là 20 ans
pour que les soins palliatifs soient
accessibles partout et pour tous de plus
une nette progression des besoins
estimés est prévu pour les années à
venir du fait du vieillissement de la
population le nombre de personnes de 75
ans et plus va augmenter d'environ 60 %
d'ici 2050 mais aujourd'hui les
objectifs d'équipement en lit spécialisé
ne sont toujours pas atteints pour six
départements métropolitains la Corse du
Sud et l'ensemble des départements et
région d'outr-emer les lits en unité de
soins palliatif sont encore moins bien
répartis 22 départements n'en disposent
pas et trois autres restent en dessous
du seuil d'un lit pour 100000 habitants
la couverture de l'ensemble du
territoire devrait devenir un objectif
de santé publique afin de permettre de
soutenir le développement des soins
palliatifs à domicile et dans les épades
de même la prise en charge palliative en
éepad est l'un des enjeux clés pour
développer l'accès aux soins palliatifs
mais le principal principal obstacle à
son développement tient dans
l'insuffisante formation des personnels
soignants et de l'ensemble du personnel
non médical intervenant en épal ainsi
l'absence d'IDE l'absence d'infirmière
pardon dans 80 % de nos épades la
l'hospitalisation à domicile pourrait
être une solution intéressante autrement
dit madame la Première ministre nous
sommes bien loin du compte c'est
pourquoi les républicains nous
proposerons ce jeudi une résolution
visant à rendre effectifs les soins
palliatifs en France parce que c'est un
droit fondamental pour nos concitoyens
consacré au sein même du Code de Santé
Publique et puisqu'il me reste quelques
minutes j'ai entendu et j'ai surtout
pris attention de de la dernière
discussion générale à à cet endroit
concernant les revendications des
infirmières et je vous ai je vous ai pas
senti convaincu quand je vous ai
effectivement euh annoncé que le premier
acte était financé à 100 % le 2è acte à
50 % et le 3è acte gratuit Je vous
confirme j'ai bien revu devant euh votre
côté un peu sceptique j'ai bien revu
l'ensemble des syndicats infirmiers je
vous confirme bien qu'il y a bien une
dégressivité des tarifs infirmiers 50 %
pour le 2e acte gratuit le 3è acte et si
on regarde n'importe quelle profession
et j'ai rien contre les plombiers les
électriciens ou autres qui
effectueraient un deux ou trois acte
dans un domicile personne n'offre le 3è
acte donc je crois qu'à l'heure où le le
le le pouvoir d'achat euh de nos
professionnels de santé de territoire et
notamment de domicile garant des virages
ambulatoires et domiciliaires je pense
que c'est une mesure urgente à prendre
plutôt que la revalorisation effective
ou en tout cas en suus du carburant
merci pour votre attention merci
Monsieur
ner la parole est à Madame M Gatel pour
le groupe
démocrate
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du
gouvernement chers
collègues notre assemblée examine
aujourd'hui une nouvelle tentative de la
nupess pour renverser le gouvernement
celui-ci ayant engagé sa responsabilité
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale une upès ressuscitée
pour l'occasion au pire moment cont tenu
des des propos ignobles tenus hier il a
fallu une fois encore que vous déposiez
une motion de censure dans un réflexe
quasi pavlovien et oui madame Amot une
fois encore vous avez prouvé qu'il
n'existe pas de majorité alternative et
d'ailleurs avez-vous même fait l'effort
d'en présenter on peine à trouver trace
d'une quelconque cohérence ou d'un réel
projet construit d'alternance dans vos
centaines d'amendements alors vous ne
l'avez pas dit Madame Amot dans votre
discours mais dans la motion de censure
vous dénoncez un projet qui je cite dét
tricote la sécurité sociale et brutalise
notre hôpital public et ses soignants or
les mots ont un sens les mots ont un
sens détricoter la sécurité sociale
croyez-vous vraiment que c'est un nom
d'âme porté à
255 milliards d'euros en 2024 alors
qu'il n'était que de 190 milliards en
2017 soit une augmentation de plus de 65
milliards brutaliser notre hôpital
public et ses soignants c'est ainsi que
vous qualifiez la continuation des
revalorisations salariales issu du Ségur
pour un montant de
3,3 milliards
d'euros le PLFSS est un tiers de la
richesse nationale quel autre pays
consacre autant à la solidarité que la
France on peut parfaite
avoir des divergces sur les évolutions
et les priorités données à notre système
de santé mais arrêtons de faire croire
au français que notre pacte social est
mis en cause c'est Sapper les fondements
de notre modèle qui fait notre fierté
c'est le contraire et ce projet de PLFSS
répond aux défis qui sont devant nous
notamment la question du vieillissement
tout en renforçant notre pacte social à
force de jouer avec les mots on abîme
profondément et je le crains durablement
notre démocratie
face à ce projet de loi qui perpétue les
principes et les exigences du modèle
social dont nous sommes les héritiers
près de
ans après la fondation de la sécurité
sociale le groupe démocrate
salue ce projet c'est en sachant
répondre à une triple exigence de
solidarité de responsabilité et
d'émancipation que nous saurons faire
œuvre utile en matiè d'action sociale
tant à l'égard de nos aïeux du Conseil
National de la Résistance qu'envers les
génér qui nous succéderont si nous avons
une dette envers les esprits novateurs
de 1945 nous avons aussi des devoirs à
l'égard de nos enfants et de nos
petits-enfants c'est dans cet esprit que
les députés démocrates ont abordé
l'examen du texte les amendements que
nous avons présentés permettaient de
garantir une meilleure protection
sociale pour tous mais sans obérer notre
capacité à faire face à nos engagements
budgétaires et financiers plusieurs
n'ont pas été retenus dans la version du
texte par le gouvernement sur lequel la
première ministre a engagé sa
responsabilité et nous le regrettons le
groupe démocrate continuera d'agir et de
défendre ses convictions dans un esprit
de concertation au service de nos
concitoyens au cours de la navette
parlementaire le Sénat a quant à lui
apporté des modifications substantielles
au texte adopté par notre assemblée le
groupe démocrate tient à souligner
l'esprit de responsabilité dont ont su
faire preuve les
sénateurs malgré des désaccords évidents
avec notre majorité notamment concernant
la trajectoire budgétaire proposée par
le gouvernement mais il est sain que
différentes visions de la protection
sociale puisse s'affronter sans perdre
de vue l'intérêt supérieur de la nation
je suis convaincu que ces visions
peuvent même se compléter je pense par
exemple à l'ambition partagée avec le
Sénat en matière de prévention ou de
soutien à l'innovation de la
santé plusieurs dispositions du projet
de loi traduisent l'exigence de
solidarité que je mentionnais tout à
l'heure
car c'est en étant solidaire que nous
serons fidèles à l'esprit des
ordonnances laroc de 45 le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2024 permet ainsi une meilleure
articulation des droits à la
complémentaire solidaire santé avec les
minimas sociaux comme l'allocation
adules handicapés l'allocation
supplémentaire d'invalidité ou celle
destinée aux chômeurs en fin de droit
solidarité aussi à travers la
suppression de T jours de carence en cas
d'arrêt de travail dû à une interruption
de grossesse solidarité encore car pour
mieux accompagner celles et ceux qui
prennent soin d'un proche malade
plusieurs fois au cours de leur vie la
collectivité prendra en charge un
renouvellement de laallocation
journalière de proch et d outre la
solidarité notre modèle social de
l'après-gerre repose sur une logique de
responsabilité c'est même la condition
syinequanon pour garantir au génération
futur un système solide aussi protecteur
que nous le connaissons aujourd'hui les
dépenses doivent être compensées par les
recettes équivalentes c'est aussi simple
que cela transmettre à nos enfants des
comptes en grave déficit d'année en
année c'est les condamnés à porter le
fardeau d'une dette sociale qui n'est
pas la leure mais la nôtre c'est
pourquoi le texte porté par cette
majorité prévoit des mesures d'économie
sur la consommation et le prix des
médicaments mais également sur les
sommes versées à l'unéic pour tenir
compte des effets des réformes de
l'assurance chômage et de l'amélioration
du marché de l'emploi également le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale vise à diminuer les
arrêts de travail non justifiés et à
inciter au recours au transports
partagés le PLFSS permet aussi à la fois
de veiller à ce que les grandes
plateformes payent ce qu'elles doivent
en renforçant les obligations
déclaratives et d'améliorer la
couverture sociale des micro et
auto-entrepreneurs cette lutte contre la
sous-déclaration des revenus dont le
manque est gagné est estimé à plusieurs
centaines de millions pour nos comptes
sociaux est essentiel pour nos comptes
publics comme pour l'acceptabilité des
prélèvements sociaux enfin agir de
manière responsable c'est être mieux
préparé aux crises le projet de loi
présente dès lors plusieurs mesures pour
lutter contre les pénuries de
médicaments mesures qui apporteront une
réponse à l'inquiétude justifiée de nos
concitoyens à mon sens la sécurité
sociale remplit pleinement son rôle
lorsqu'elle permet à chacun d'être
acteur de son destin notamment face à la
dégradation de l'état de santé c'est
tout l'objet des rendez-vous aux cl de
la vie que le projet de loi propose de
plus facilement généraliser comme de la
prise en charge inédite des moyens de
contraception ou de la généralisation de
la vaccination
HPV solidarité responsabilité
émancipation pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe démocrate s'opposera à cette
motion de censure je vous remercie merci
Madame
Gattel la parole est à Monsieur Arthur
de laaporte pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté
[Applaudissements]
présidente merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
chers
collègues madame la Première ministre
vendredi après midi vous êtes monté à la
tribune et vous avez avant même que les
députés nai pu piper mot déclenché votre
20e 493 c'est peut-être votre côté bon
élève madame la Première ministre 20 sur
20 franchement bravo bravo vous aurez
mention très bien avec les félicitations
du président de la République pour avoir
rudoyé sans vergogne le Parlement avec
votre projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui continue de
détruire notre modèle social pas sûr
néanmoins que les Françaises et les
Français vous en soi si
reconnaissant ce petit sourire satisfait
que vous afficher désormais quand vous
déclenchez un 493 il peut-être perçu par
certains comme le signe d'une forme de
déconnexion voire d'une ignorance de la
réalité vécue par nombre de nos
concitoyens Tanton puisque vous êtes
présente ici de leur donner la parole on
en est même plus à choisir entre le
loisir ou manger les loisirs ça fait
belle urette qu'on s'en passe on en
serait plutôt à choisir entre les œufs
et le lait mais pas les deux ou entre le
liquide vaisselle et le gel douche de
nouveau mais pas les deux quand on peut
encore en prendre un des mots comme ce
message posté sur ma page facebook la
semaine dernière à la suite de votre
précédente motion de censure il nous
touche unlassablement depuis un an et
demi alors que l'inflation on le dit on
le répète on le Martelle elle pèse sur
les ménages pendant ce temps vous allez
généreusement revaloriser le RSA de 4,6
% et les pensions de retraite de 5,4 %
franchement bravo ça fait 90 centimes de
plus par jour pour un allocataire du RSA
alors après ils vont continuer de se
plaindre comme Juliette que l'on réduise
le montant de la loocation alors qu'ils
ont oublié de déclarer 40 € quand même
de vente d'objets sur le boncoin c'était
dans un article du Monde madame la
Première ministre je vous en ferai
parvenir une copie franchement c'est ind
descent s ses assistés au bout du
rouleau ils auseraient encore se
plaindre parce que on les contrôle un
contrôle technocratique et inhumain mais
oui quelle indécence peut-être ces
chiffres ces éléments sur l'inflation
sont-ils encore trop abstrait 3,45 € le
paquet de yaourt sur le site de
Carrefour il y a moins d'une heure ce
même paquet qui coûtait 2,72 € il y a 1
an cette différence elle n'est pas
ridicule c'est le quotidien de nos
concitoyens alors madame la Première
ministre puisque à l'instar de ministre
du Travail vous ne m'écoutez pas ou trop
peu vous allez peut-être prêter
attention à ce que nous disent les
banques alim entire leur rapport
décrivent méthodiquement comment la
précarisation de l'emploi rallonge les
fils d'attente aux distribution
organisées par des bénévoles savez-vous
que parmi les effectifs qui sollicitent
l'aide des Banques Alimentaires 60 %
travaillent à temps partiel c'est la
fabque de l'emploi précaire qui conduit
à renforcer la pauvreté les bas salaires
et les classes moyennes sont pénalisés
par cette trappe à pauvreté qui est
l'inflation madame la Première ministre
puisque vous avez souhaité interrompre
notre parole pour la 20e fois
laissez-moi donc continuer de leur
donner la parole à ces acteurs de la
solidarité qui sont le dernier refuge de
celles et ceux que vos politiques
précarise vendredi matin pendant que
vous pour fourbissiez ce 20e 493 j'étais
à 11h à la Banque Alimentaire du
Calvados au côté des bénévoles et des
2,5 salariés pour les écouter je leur ai
promis de relayer leurs paroles à
bredeville sur Rondon l'entrepôt est
trop petit il faudrait qu'il soit trois
fois plus grand pour gérer la demande
les périodes
où les aides comme le RSA ne sont pas
encore versés ça met évidemment les gens
en difficulté ils sont isolés ils sont
perdus lors d'une faillette de commerce
par exemple les gens n'ont pas de chôage
pas de revenus rien si les restau du
cœur refusent désormais les 100 plus
riches ils vont aller toquer à d'autres
portes mais lesquels personne évidemment
n'a envie de refuser les gens de trier
entre les pauvres de plus en plus de
travailleurs pauvres viennent ça pose
d'ailleurs des questions pour les
banques alimentaire du Calvados c'est
même aujourd'hui Amazon qui donne un
chèque de 12000 € pour pouvoir ch des
conserves Amazon qui met à disposition
des camions et des chauffeurs oui oui
vous avez bien entendu c'est amazone
championne de l'optimisation fiscale
professionnelle des conditions de
travail dégradé des cadences infernales
des rotations à la chaîne qui se
substituent à l'état pour financer les
Banques Alimentaires quel symbole
pourriez-vous assumer devant la
représentation nationale le montant des
exonérations d'impôts qu'entraînent
cette politique par ailleurs de
responsabilité sociale environmentale de
l'entreprise
américaine samedi à 10h le lendemain
j'ai été invité en Ardèche pour parler
travail emploi et défendre une autre
vision que celle qui est portée par
votre Ministre du Travail Olivier du
sopt auuteille j'ai rencontré
l'association Territoire zéro chômeurs
longue durée qui porte un ambitieux
projet de transformation des
territoirees et dont vous vouliez
réduire les subventions à priva nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des salariés
d'une ressourcerie qui déplore que votre
gouvernement détourne le modèle des
ateliers et des chantiers d'insertion
nous accompagnons de plus en plus de
personnes de 50 ans de moins de 25 ans
la semaine dernière une dame âgée de 66
ans est venue nous voir elle n'avait pas
de solution la dernière réforme de
l'assurance chômage a beaucoup changé
les choses des personnes qui avant
pouvaient payer leur facture nous
disent-ils n'y arrivent plus nous avons
même une bénéficiaire qui a une licence
de langue étrangère appliqué lea tout
est déréglé les réformes comme celle de
l'assurant chômage renvoient les gens
vers le RSA il y a une colère forte les
gens vivent dans des logements pourris
ce sont des
Invisibles vous n'avez pas augmenté les
plafonds des chantiers d'assertion il y
a une réduction du nombre de personnes
qui peuvent aller vers les dispositifs
d'assertion c'est votre politique 1
heure plus tard j'étais à la rencontre
des des bénévoles du Secours populaire
il n'y a pas eu de distribution en
novembre nous disent-il car nous n'avons
plus de stock c'est difficile notre
Secrétaire général a alerté madame borne
sur l'utilisation des fonds européens de
l'aide alimentaire qui ne sont pas
consommé en France nous n'avons pas
d'étudiants sur notre territoire
ajoute-t-il mais nous avons désormais
des lycéens qui viennent prendre des
paquets de biscuits dans nos territoires
ruraux même l'accès au droit est en
danger puisque ce déplacer coûte trop
cher les gens n'ont plus les moyens de
venir chercher à manger les gens
viennent mais on n pas prêt on n'est pas
France service bis on ne peut pas
compenser par des appels à projets à
durabilité limitée à un moment on se
pose la question jusqu'à quel moment
devra-t-on se battre pour avoir quelques
subsides de l'état pour accompagner son
désengagement ce désengagement de l'État
je ne peux que le constater dans le
Calvados votre département à wistream je
vous l'ai dit dimanche dernier des
hommes sont frigorifiés ils attendent
une mise à l'abri qui est votre devoir
mais qui tarde alors même que
l'hébergement d'urgence est saturé faute
de moyens notamment il gèle madame la
Première ministre il pleut il n'y a pas
assez de tente et ils doivent se relayer
pour dormir plus de la moitié d'entre
eux a déposé une demande d'asile mais en
attendant en ce moment ils n'ont droit à
rien ils n'ont rien ils sont considérés
comme moins que rien à wistream comme on
me le rappelait à la banque alimentaire
il y a de plus en plus de jeunes
certains 12 13 ans la Croix Rouge a du
mal à trouver des bénévoles pour aller
leur donner à manger à cause de la gale
et de la tuberculose nous n'avons pas
une ligne de crédit sur la marude à
wistream pour avoir de l'aide
alimentaire alors il y a wiistriam mais
il y a diankkerer il y a calé partout
des campements de fortune et des exilés
qui cherchent tout simplement à survivre
et qui ne désire qu'une chose pour la
plupart vivre travailler s'intégrer en
France vivre dignement et pendant ce
temps-là il y a votre Ministre du
Logement qui dit dans le monde j'ai 1600
migrants à dunkererc je les gère c'est
ce qui me paraît plus important par
contre c'est que les gens ne soient pas
étranglés par leur rythme de vie et leur
pouvoir d'achat bravo Monsieur le
Ministre du Logement mais quand vous
voyez malgré votre en même temps qui
divise les gens sont sont quand même
étranglés par leur rythme de vie et leur
pouvoir d'achat à cause de vos
politiques et en même temps votre devoir
notre honneur devrait aussi être de
considérer les exilés autrement comme
des chiffres qu'on gère
l'indignité au-delà de ces propos c'est
évidemment celle des conditions dans
lesquelles on accueille notamment ceux
qui sont à attraper sur nos frontières
laissez-moi madame la Première ministre
vous raconter ce que j'ai vu à Menton
menton dans le poste de police de
frontière c'est un local de mise à
l'abri dans une courette ce sont parfois
des dizaines d'hommes qui attendent en
plein cagnard qui dorment sur des bans
en métal pour quelques-uns mais surtout
sur le sol goudronné à l'intérieur dans
une salle de 30 m²r ce sont des mineurs
des familles des bébés qui se partagent
quatre matelas de sol ils sont une
quarantaine une toilette à la turque
putride et un point d'eau des bébés
madame la Première ministre des bébés
qui don dorment ici je garderai toujours
en mémoire l'image de ce couple avec
leur toute petit fill de 9 mois qui
rentrait à 20h30 dans le poste ils vont
passer la nuit là à même le sol le
lendemain je les ai retrouvé par hasard
à 2 m000es il n'avaient évidemment pas
dormi ils avaient fui la Guinée et
l'excision au poste on leur a demandé
leur identité mais pas s'ils voulait
l'asile mais pas s'il voulaiit voir un
médecin leur petite fille était malade
depuis 3 semaines au poste on les a
conduit dans cette pièce surpeuplée où
la petite fille a dormit sur l'épaule de
son père allangé sur le carelage sale à
8h on les a remis dehors 2h de marche le
long de la route vers l'Italie madame le
fr madame la Première ministre ça ne
peut pas être la France c'est la France
vendredi dernier je suis revenu en
commission des lois et j'ai assisté
médusé à vos renoncements durcissement
du regroupement familial durcissement du
droit du titre de séjour étranger malad
exigence d'un niveau de maîtrise de
langue alors même qu'il n'y a plus de
place dans les centres de
langu madame la Première ministre pour
finir je vais vous parler de samasa
samasa elle fait le ménage à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis 40 ans elle n to depuis
plus de 30 ans les bancs sur lesquels
vous êtes assis elle peine à joindre les
de bouts elle a abandonné sa demande de
naturalisation sans rancune avec le
sourire parce qu'il manqua une pièce
mais elle continue de venir nettoyer
votre banquette elle a eu des problèmes
de 68 de santé elle a 68 ans elle
continue de travailler aujourd'hui je
pense à elle je pense à ceux qui font
tourner la France malgré vos politiques
avec abnégation et sentiment des devoirs
madame la Première ministre au nom
d'unumité technocratique qui vous sert
de politique nous vteront la
censure merci Monsieur de la
porte la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
Valtou pour le groupe horizon et
apparenté madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Mesdames et Messieurs
les les ministres mes chers
collègues l'article 493 la Constitution
est une disposition légale c'est une
disposition démocratique au sens où elle
est inscrite dans notre constitution
c'est une disposition pour dépasser les
situations de blocage lorsque
l'essentiel est en jeu et donner un
cadre budgétaire à toutes nos politiques
sanitaires et sociales c'est un sujet
essentiel par contre la motion de
censure qui est éventuellement son
pendant est aussi une disposition légale
mais c'est surtout un outil politique
dont l'efficacité se juge au résultat
obtenu au nombre de de voix qu'elle
fédère et de ce point de vue là mesdames
et messieurs les députés de la nupes le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'avec
toutes vos motions ce réflexe pavlovien
comme été dit et comme je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises de dégainer ces
motions vous avez fait pit vous avez
fait pit dès la première fois vous avez
persisté puis vous avez refait pchit
puis vous avez re refait pchit puis vous
avez re re re refait chip puis patatera
puis repchit ce n'est plus avec de vrais
arguments politiques que vous montez à
l'assaut de à l'occasion de toutes ces
motions de rejet de renvois ou de
censure ce sont malheureusement des
pistolets à eut que vous brandissez avec
l'idée certainement des que laabousé
Larche ça on a bien compris mais
quelques gouttes d'eau ça sèche et
surtout ça laisse pas beaucoup de trac
et nous motion après motion nous vous
écoutons mais surtout nous vous
regardons vous empêtrer dans vos
contradictions et vos arguments tirés à
boulet rouge nous vous regardons être de
moins en moins suivi par vos alliés être
de moins en moins nombreux sur ces bans
à la soutenir et nous regrettons que
dans cet hémicycle cet état d'esprit est
pris le pas sur l'échange constructif
comme pourtant nous nous pouvons l'avoir
fait en commission à plusieurs reprises
pour la 5e fois nous avons beau vous
écouter et nous vous écoutons
patiemment nous n'entendons rien nous
n'entendons aucune proposition
structurer aucun projet alternatif qui
puisse surtout fédérer largement dans
cet hémicycle et finalement faire une
majorité alternative car hélas chers
collègues critiquer ce que propose le
gouvernement et la majorité ne suffit
pas ça ne suffit pas à construire une
majorité responsable cohérente et
capable de proposer aux Français un
projet qui serait différent du nôutre
finalement ce rejet systématique fait
surtout naître une forme de regret celui
de ne pas avoir pu percevoir le modèle
social que vous auriez souhaité dessiner
dans le cadre du PLFSS pour 2024 mais la
ré ité reste là vous avez plutôt opté
pour les critiques les mensonges les
contrevérités les approximations et les
postures dont acte dont acte au nom du
groupe horizon je salue ceux qui ont
donné la primoté à l'intérêt général
ceux qui n'ont pas cédé à la tentation
simpliste des carcans idéologiques de la
part du gouvernement cette attitude
constructive s'est manifestée par une
main souvent tendue aux oppositions
reprenant notamment certains des
amendements nous l'avons aussi nous
majorités repris certains de vos
amendements en commission et vous le
savez rappelons quelques chiffres en
2024 nous finançons 105 milliards
d'euros pour l'hôpital nous finançons
254 millions milliards pardon d'euros au
titre de londam nous finançons 284
milliards pour l'assurance vieillesse ou
encore 58 milliards pour les dépenses de
politique familiale tous ces budgets
sont en augmentation et c'est inédit je
le répète notre majorité n'a pas à
rougir de ces chiffres ces budgets c'est
la revalorisation des pensions de
retraite de plus de 5 %. ces budgets
c'est plus de 3 milliards d'euros de
revalorisation des personnels sanitaires
médicaux-sociaux et de la petite enfance
en parallèle il nous incombe aussi de
maîtriser les dépenses quand elles
peuvent l'être grâce à des à des
économies raisonnées garantissant
l'équilibre global du système tout en
maintenant les droits des Français je
l'ai indiqué à plusieurs reprises à
cette tribune depuis le début de
l'examen du texte il est indispensable
de s'inscrire pleinement dans une
trajectoire de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques à l'heure où la menace des
déficits est présente et que l'inflation
commence à refluer ce PLFSS poursuit cet
objectif et se trouve dans la lignée de
la boussole du groupe horizon selon
laquelle chaque euro des Français doit
être dépensé de façon juste et efficace
dans ce contexte nous soulignons un
objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie qui reste dynamique
en 2024 à plus 3,2 % accompagné de
l'esquise de réforme structurante
nécessaire et d'une trajectoire de 3,5
milliards d'euros d'économie fondée sur
l'efficience de la politique de santé
publique ces économies s'accompagnent de
mesures de responsabilisation des
acteurs du système de santé de mesures
de lutte contre la faute sociale contre
la fraude sociale pardon impératif
d'équité et de justice pour l'ensemble
des assurés le PLFSS pour 2024 s'attaque
aussi à à plusieurs priorités dont
l'accélération du virage préventif la
lutte contre toutes les inégalités
d'accès à la santé et le financement de
l'hôpital et des épades en premier lieu
au sujet de la prévention qui a été
historiquement un parent pauvre des
politiques de santé je me réjouis et
nous devrions tous nous en réjouir du
lancement de la grande campagne de
vaccination contre les infections liées
au papioma virus prise en charge à 100 %
dans tous les collèges pour les élèves
de 5e la gratuité des préservatifs pour
les moins de 26 ans et la prise en
charge des protections monstruelles
réutilisables pour les jeunes femmes et
notamment les plus précaires l'accès aux
soins est une préoccupation majeure des
Français là encore vous auriez pu vous
réjouir de plusieurs avancées prévues
dans ce texte je pense notamment à
l'élargissement des compétences des
pharmaciens en leur permettant de
prescrire des antibiotiques après la
réalisation d'un test d'orientation
diagnostique pour les engines et les
cystites je pense aussi à la
généralisation d'une expérimentation
réformant l'organisation des soins
dentaires déjà déployés dans 10 régions
et 26 départements c'est une mesure de
bon sens qui qui permettra de répondre
aux besoins urgents de la population
enfin ce PLFSS marque une étape
importante dans les réformes de
financement de tous les secteurs d'une
part il pose le premier jalon de la
sortie du tout et deux a à l'hôpital que
beaucoup appelai leur vœux depuis si
longtemps et promis par le Président de
la République au début de l'année
d'autre part il entame une réforme
importante du financement des épades en
donnant la possibilité au départements
qui le souhaitent de de s'y inscrire de
fusionner les sections de financement
soins et dépenses et de transférer son
financement à la branche autonomie ce
plfssés et représente ainsi un pas de
plus vers le long chemin du redressement
de notre système de soins j'ai bien
entendu quelques regrets notamment sur
les sujets liés au sportsanté lié au
sujet des rendez-vous nonhonorés lié
aussi au sujet de lutte contre l'alcool
et contre le tabagisme mais je sais
aussi que notre politique sociale ne
peut résider dans le seul véhicule
législatif du PLFSS il faut engager des
réformes structurelles pour faire
évoluer notre système de santé nous
allons faire au niveau local grâce au au
vote prochain de la proposition loi que
j'ai l'honneur de de présenter et de
rapporter sur l'accès aux soins c'est un
pas supplémentaire vers la
territorialisation de notre système de
santé car oui il faut faire confiance
aux acteurs de terrain oui il faut
discuter de la la question de
l'efficacité des dépenses publiques au
plus près de là où elles sont dépensées
en prenant en considération les
priorités de santé publique et en
garantissant des rémunération juste et
équitable oui il faut aussi changer
d'époque en matière de prévention oui
enfin il faut obtenir des acteurs de
santé qu'il changent certaines de leurs
habitudes moderniser notre système de
santé passe par des réformes audacieuses
qui certes bousculeront des rentes
bousculeront des habitudes mais c'est à
ce prix et à ce seul prix que nous
pourrons le péréniser nous sommes à un
moment historique qui oblige chacun à
débattre avec sincérité et donc avec
l'envie de chercher des compromis et des
solutions plutôt que de s'opposer par
posture et par plaisir cet état d'esprit
cette volonté de privilégier l'intérêt
général plutôt que les intérêts
partisans ne sont pas partagés sur tous
les ban de cet hémicycle et c'est bien
dommage groupe Horizon a pris lui toute
sa part dans dans l'élaboration de ce
pfss sur certains points notamment sur
la santé des femmes il a permis des
avancées très concrètes en conclusion le
493 n'est pas un délit de démocratie
mais un outil de stabilité de notre 5e
République c'est pourquoi madame la
Première ministre le groupe horizon vous
renouvelle tout son soutien et ne votera
évidemment pas cette nouvelle motion de
censure merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
Valtou la parole est à Madame Julie
lernous pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres madame la
Première ministre vous avez banalisé
l'usage du 493 sur les textes
budgétaires imperturbable vous continuez
de dégainer texte après texte si l'année
précédente vous aviez maintenu
l'illusion du débat parlementaire en
entendant quelques jours de débat avant
d'enclencher le 493 cette année vous
vous donnez même plus la peine de jouer
la comédie votre dernier 493 le 20e a
duré à peine 2 minutes preuve du
caractère dérisoire banal presque anodin
que prennent à présent ces 493 vous
amputez les discussions avant même
qu'elle n'it pu avoir lieu vous clôturez
le débat avant même qu'il n'it commencé
mais en réalité recourir au 493 révèle
votre profonde fragilité force de
constater que vous êtes dans
l'incapacité de réunir une majorité pour
faire vos textes
austéritaires même les députés de votre
propre camp désertent d'orénavant les
commissions préalables aux discussions
budgétaire sachant qu'aucune
modification ne se jou à là vous imposez
du haut sans faire jouer à la démocratie
cette voix essentielle celle pour
laquelle nous parlementaires avons été
élus par le peuple celle de la
représentation de la pluralité projet de
loi de finance après projet de loi de
finance PLFSS après PLFSS vous continuez
de déconstruire notre pacte républicain
et le fondement de notre démocratie les
493 sont la vie de votre laaveu de votre
faiblesse ce mépris de la démocratie est
loin d'être sans conséquence pour notre
pays au-delà de l'affront pour les
parlementaires il y a une répercussion
très concrète sur la vie des Françaises
et des Français bien loin de nos joutes
politiques et de nos querelles
parlementaire car ce n'est pas seulement
la représentation nationale que vous
méprisez à chaque fois que vous montez à
la tribune pour user et abuser de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
ce sont toutes les Françaises et les
Français c'est l'espoir d'une démocratie
qui prend en compte chacune et chacun la
promesse républicaine de ne laisser
personne au bord de la route en passant
en force réforme après réforme texte
après texte vous contribuez à dégoûter
un peu plus encore les Françaises et les
Français de la politique vous méprisez
ainsi leurs préoccupations les
répercussions sur leur quotidien vous
donnez l'impression que le politique que
la politique n'est l'affaire que de
quelquesun mais n'est pas l'affaire du
peuple et vous affaiblissez ainsi
considérablement la promesse
républicaine et
démocratique à quoi bon participer à
quoi bon manifester à quoi bon voter à
force de refuser de taxer les super
profit en étant la main et l'oreille des
grandes entreprises des lobbyes vous
renforcez la perception des Français
d'être dirigé par une élite faible avec
les puissants et forte avec les faibles
au puissants on laisse tout passer au
faible rien en passant en force sur la
réforme des retraites vous dédaignez les
souffrances physiques et psychologiques
des plus vulnérable et ce faisant vous
creusez encore le gouffre entre ceux qui
gouvernent et ceux qui subissent vous
avez choisi d'ignorer des millions de
Françaises et de Français qui ont marché
contre votre réforme dans une
mobilisation historique vous vous n'avez
pas entendu les sincères revendications
de celles et ceux qui ont dénoncé son
caractère profondément injuste plutôt
que d'agir sur un des défis majeurs de
notre siècle celui de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique vous choisissez
de criminaliser celles et ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à se résoudre à laisser
les pétroliers forer les sols les élites
conruire construire des autoroutes pour
les riches en dépit de toutes les
alertes des scientifiques qu'ils soient
climatologues ou environnementalistes
en choisissant de passer en force madame
la Première ministre vous trahissez la
promesse républicaine et démocratique
vous manquez à votre responsabilité
celle de trouver le meilleur compromis
social pour une société déjà très
fragilisée et profondément fracturé
aujourd'hui votre gouvernement n'est
plus le rempart face à l'extrême droite
qu'il a prétendu être il est au
contraire devenu son trempelin à force
de creuser les inégalités sociales et
économiques à à force de mener des
politiques antisociales et
antiécologiques vous devenez acteur de
la montée du populisme dans notre pays
alors que vous avez été élu avec les
voix de la gauche et des écologistes
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite
vous don donnez aujourd'hui raison au
discours populiste aineux xénophobe et
nationaliste de l'extrême droite vous
mettez à l'agenda des débats comme
l'immigration sur lesquels l'extrême
droite prospère dans un vain espoir de
détourner l'attention et de capter la
colère de celles et ceux qui sont exclus
vous assumez de faire une pause
environnementale alors que l'arrêt de
ces politique marque là aussi le refus
de croire en l'avenir et vous
crédibilisez là aussi un peu plus le
discours de l'extrême droite qui pointe
l'écologie comme l'origine de tous les
mots et les contraintes plutôt que
d'agir réellement contre le
réchauffement climatique même les cops
deviennent un prétexte pour disséminer
votre idéologie technosolutionniste au
côté des pétroliers
mais surtout vous continuez de
déconstruire méthodiquement les services
publics qui constituent le patrimoine de
celles et ceux qui n'en possèdent pas
protection sociale assurance chômage
retraite mais aussi l'égalité d'accès
aux soins à l'hôpital public et à
l'éducation une société qui n'investit
plus dans sa jeunesse dans l'éducation
qui est le pilier de la démocratie de la
promesse républicaine est une société
qui abandonne toute forme de progrès
social et ne croit plus en son avenir
c'est pourtant ce que vous faites
saboter notre système d'éducation
nationale en voulant créer des classes
de niveau l'école publique pour les
pauvres le privé pour les
privilégiés l'explosion du nombre
d'enfants qui dorment dans la rue sur
laquelle nous tentons d'agir de vous
interpeller par tous les moyens mon
collègue char fourni a même mis à
disposition sa permanence parlementaire
pour se faire et la conséquence de vos
politiques
défaillantes vous refusez de mettre à
contribu tion les industries les plus
polluantes pour financer notre système
de santé Vous refusez de débloquer les
financements nécessaires pour mener une
véritable politique de rénovation des
logements vous laissez de plus en plus
de ménages au prises avec la précarité
énergétique et vous continuez de fermer
les yeux sur notre système judiciaire
qui demande aux femmes victimes de
prouver l'agression sexuelle ou le viol
et pas aux agresseurs de prouver leur
innocence vous laissez notre système de
santé publique se détériorer sur le dos
des aides soignantes infirmière et
médecins qui le pent à bout droit bras
notre système de santé mentale est en
lambau avec des conséquences dramatiques
là aussi en agissant ainsi en creusant
les inégalités
socio-économiques en appauvrissant notre
modèle de solidarité vous créez une
brèche dans laquelle l'extrême droite
n'a qu'à s'engouffrer et s'engouffre
déjà vous crédibiliser leur discours
pire vous les faites prospérer or à quoi
mènent les inég ité économique la crise
de confiance envers les gouvernements le
dégoût de la politique et la perte de
fois envers le système que nous enseigne
l'Italie la Hongrie la Suède la
Slovaquie et plus récemment à mon grand
désespoir les Pays-Bas l'accroissement
des inégalités la défiance envers les
élites politiques mène à la montée du
populisme ne tirez-vous aucune leçon de
tous ces exemples où votrerponsabilité
va-t-elle nous mener je pourrais vous
parler de ma collèue de mon dégoût mais
aujourd'hui c'est de mon grande
inquiétude qu'il s'agit si nous
choisissons de censurer votre
gouvernement c'est pour marquer notre
opposition à cette montée du populisme
que vous assumez puisque vos politiques
la nourrissent directement madame la
Première ministre je vois la démocratie
en Europe brûlée et votre gouvernement
en recourant systématiquement au 493
jette de l'huile sur l'incendie
mesurez-vous véritablement les
répercussions de ce dé de démocratie à
répétition pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe écologiste votera cette motion de
censure et j'invite tous les
parlementaires à faire de même je vous
remercie merci Madame
lernous la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe de la
Gauche démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine
ce matin madame la Première ministre
madame la Présidente ce matin en me
réveillant grippé je me suis demandé si
c'est votre politique qui m'avait rendu
malade mais je n'oserai évidemment pas
faire cette
allusion devant vous
permettre au Parlement de se prononcer
chaque année sur le financement de la
sécurité sociale est une nécessité
démocratique et la condition de
l'instauration d'un équilibre de notre
système de protection sociale il est
essentiel que le Parlement puisse voter
chaque année une lo de financement de la
sécurité sociale ces mots ne devrai pas
vous choquer ils sont de chez vous ils
sont d'Alain Jup en
1996 en 96 une révision
constitutionnelle reconnaissait enfin
que le budget de la SCU exigeait un
débat politique et le vote du Parlement
ces mots n'ont pas pris une ride et il
est bon que vous les entendiez ce jour
où pour la 20e fois nous ripostons par
une motion de censure à votre décision
de priver les représentants de la nation
du débat qui est la respiration de la
démocratie ce débat qu'aucune autre
démocratie parlementaire ne songerait à
passer à la trappe comme vous le faites
oui
le budget de la Sécurité sociale est une
affaire politique il n'y a pas plus
politique que la santé puisquil N a pas
plus important que la santé quand la
santé va tout va qui à part vous et le
président de la République oserait
remettre en cause des prérogatives de
notre Parlement à débattre ou à voter le
budget de la Sécurité sociale j'ai du
mal à me tourner vers mes collègues
marcheurs ils sont absents mais il faut
qu'il mesure le poids de l'acte
d'autorité qu'ils
approuvent comment prétendre fixer les
dépenses de santé sans tenir compte
véritablement des besoins comment
prétendre déterminer les recettes qui
seront affectées à la sécurité sociale
sans au préalable avoir un débat
politique sur la nature des ressources
vous madame la Première ministre contre
la volonté du constituant
1996 vous décidez que le budget de la
SCU peut être arrêté par l'exécutif seul
sans débat politique entre technocrate
plus soucieux de la carte bleu que de la
carte vitale en tout cas sans aucune
contradiction le 493 nous vous le
répétons abîme la démocratie le 493
appliqué au budget de la SCU abîme la
démocratie sociale ce budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour 2024 arrêté donc
d'une manière autoritaire n'aurait pas
été le même si nous en avions débattu je
ne sais pas si vous êtes allé dans un
hôpital récemment pas pour une visite
organisée ripoliné mais pour une vraie
visite une visite vérité ou si vous avez
regardé sur le service public de France
3 le documentaire éloquant intitulé nous
soignant une enquête de plus qui met des
mots sur les mots de notre système de
santé une enquête qui permet de mesurer
que le budget de la Sécurité sociale que
vous imposez n'est pas à la hauteur des
besoins de santé si un vrai débat débat
avait eu lieu nous aurions pu faire la
démonstration du gouffre qui existe
entre ce que vous mettez sur la table
pour notre système sé et ses besoins
réels nous aurions pu vous dire pourquoi
ce que l'on voit à l'hôpital ce qui est
diffusé à la télévision et ce qu'analyse
la Fédération hospitalière de France
disqualifie le PLFSS 2024 comme le
précédent
d'ailleurs pour 2023 les besoins de
financement supplémentaires étaient de 3
milliards d'euros pour 2024 ils sont à 5
milliard d'euros quelle crise ce nouveau
fossé va-t-il ajouter à la crise s'il y
avait eu un débat nous aurions pu
examiner les sources de recettes
nouvelles pour la sécurité sociale
discuter d'urgence qu'il y a à
resocialiser notre SCU pour qu'elle
continue de tenir son rôle précieux
d'amortisseur de crise d'amortisseur de
choc la squ c'est le bien de ceux qui
n'en ont pas ceux qui comme vous
choisissent de la diminuer représentent
les gens qui ont du bien et qui en ont
le moins besoin c'est cela que vous
écoutez avec le budget de la SC qui
n'est pas à la haute
que vous imposez sans débat c'est à eux
que vous obéissez avec ce 493 et ce
n'est pas à la France des classes
moyennes et populaire pas à la France
qui souffre pas à la France malade que
vous vous référez car la crise est
profonde 6,7 millions de personnes dont
800000 en infection longue durée sont
encore à ce jour sans médecin traitant
et vous refusez toutes les mesures que
nous portons dans ce domainel il n'y a
qu'une place en épade pour 10 personnes
de plus de 75 ans avec un reste à charge
moyen à hauteur de 1957 € par mois
163 services des urgences ont fermé au
moins ponctuellement ces derniers mois
l'été dernier le dél moyens d'accès à
des consultations à l'hôpital est de 1 à
4 mois pour les pour plus de la moitié
des établissements en psychiatrie de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent 45 % des
établissements font état de délai
d'accès à l'ambulatoire compris entre 5
mois et plus d'un an c'est vous dire la
détresse de la psychiatrie tournée vers
l'enfance et la jeunesse le manque riant
de reconnaissance et la pénibilité
croissante nourrissent un absentéisme de
l'ordre de 10 % et explique que les 5 %
de pocoignant N pourvu au sein des
hôpitaux et les centres médicaux sociaux
ne risquent pas de d'être comblés vous
savez je suis euh président d'un conseil
territorial de santé vous savez cette
instance de démocratie sanitaire et cet
exemple pourrait valoir pour tous les
hôpitaux de France et de Navar sa ce
qu'on me dit dans les couloirs de
l'hôpitalur le député on s'habitue au
pire quand les gens nous disent de quoi
vous plaignez-vous ça va mieux que
l'année dernière la situation épidémique
est moins pire au mieux on hausse les
épaules au pire on s'agace mais le plus
souvent c'est la lcitude qui l'emporte
parce que le ça va mieux est en
trompleil est un trompil qui rassure les
ARS et le ministère pour l'instant les
épidémies hivernales sont certes sous
contrôle mais l'hiver est loin d'être
terminé et de nombreux établissements ne
sont pas en situation d'avoir même un
plan en hôpital en tension à la hauteur
des standards que vous exigez pour
reprendre un seul exemple les lit
d'hôpital je parle des lit physique du
matériel sur lequel on allonge le malade
de nombreux établissements ont différé
les investissements ces dernières années
faute de moyen ils ont tiré sur la corde
alors ils peuvent se retrouver avec un
nombre insuffisant lit pour cocher
toutes les cases du Plan Hôpital en
tension c'est vous dire il y a à
l'hôpital une dette d'obsolescence du
matériel par défaut d'investissement que
vous nous soupçonnez pas c'est invisible
pour le public mais les soignants le
mesure chaque jour dans leur travail ça
pèse sur le moral et ça provoque une
forme de violence
institutionnelle l'absence de capacité
d'investissement l'absence de
perspective génère une perte d'espoir
dans le système sur surtout chez les
jeunes qui démarrent leur carrière les
plus anciens supportent parce qu'ils
attendent la retraite que vous avez
d'ailleurs décidé de différer si le
quotidien semble aller un peu moins mal
que l'année dernière sur le plan
financier c'est la douche froide les
déficits des hôpitaux s'accroissent même
quand ils augmentent leur activité et
ces déficits réduisent à pot de chagrin
leur capacité d'investissement comme je
le disais tout à l'heure l'inflation
fait mal les taux d'intérêt font mal les
banques se font prier pour prêté à
l'hôpital le système de financement fait
mal la tarification à l'acte reste
malgré vos annonces à l'ordre du jour et
les mesures de compensation restent sous
la ligne de flottaison on me dit il y a
beaucoup d'annonces sur les efforts
financiers déployés sur le soutien de
l'hôpital mais ça n'arrive pas sur le
terrain concrètement rien ne reflète ces
annonces observez les promotion des
futurs directeurs et directrices elles
se réduisent preuve que l'absence de
perspective et l'absence poir que
produit l'incapacité de l'hôpital à
investir sont en train de décourager les
voocation y compris dans les directions
des établissements quand vous dites à
une équipe de travailler sur un projet
de santé pour son territoire c'est
compliqué il vous regarde en pensant qu'
n'y arrive déjà pas au jour le jour
alors comment penser à préparer le
projet médical de santé pour demain
aprèsdemain dans ces conditions et
désormais cette situation féage d'huile
dans le
médicosocial
madame la Première ministre faut-il
rappeler que les débats dans cet
hémicycle ne sont pas un entre soi ils
sont publics ils intéressent la
population pour autant qu'ils existent
vous privez de parolle les Français et
contribuez à la colère et à la
fragilisation de la démocratie en
matière d'accès au soin oui j'ai vu que
personne n'écoutait mais c'est c'est une
c'est une question de
d'habitude en matière d'accès aux soins
depuis que vous gouvernez la situation
n'a cessé de se dégrader
ce n'est pas à coup de 493 que vous
parviendrez à faire disparaître cette
réalité et atteindre à éteindre la voix
de ceux qui nous alerte cette motion de
censure est là pour vous le rappeler et
rappeler que le combat politique pour un
droit à la santé pour tous dans notre
pays et en tout cas dans notre esprit ne
s'arrête pas ce 4 décembre je vous
remercie pour votre non attention merci
monuro
est groupe liberté indépendant outre ma
et
territoire bien madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
nous voilà arrivé au terme d'un exercice
fondamental pour notre société frustré
et déçu avec le sentiment pour la
seconde année consécutive de ne pas
avoir joué notre rôle de
parlementaire avec la mauvaise
impression d'avoir été spectateur de
décisions prises seul par le
gouvernement simple spectateur et pas
même un peu commentateur puisqu'il n'y a
pas eu de débat ne nous risquons pas à
comptabiliser le nombre d'heures
consacré à la discussion des articles et
des amendements de ce projet de loi il
est inversement proportionnel à
l'importance des sujets qu'il aborde
quel a été l'intention du législateur
sur le budget de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2024 nul ne le sait vraiment
celui-ci comporte en sensin des mesures
majeures sans qu'aucun mot aucune
explication n'ait pu être exprimé ici
même aucune discussion sur la réforme
attendue de la tarification de
l'activité qui n'est ni plus ni moins
que la manière dont nous finançons nos
hôpitaux aucun débat sur notre politique
pour les médicaments alors que les
pénuries obligent certains patients à
traverser la frontière pour se procurer
les traitements j'oserais rappeler une
information l'élection du président et
des députés qui composent sa minorité au
Parlement ne suffit pas à vous donner
les mains libre pour mettre en œuvre
votre
politique la configuration quasi inédite
de notre assemblée devrait chaque jour
vous inciter au dialogue c'est
d'ailleurs la promesse qui a été faite
au lendemain des élections législatives
et c'est une promesse que nous vous
rappellerons tant qu'il le faudra car
nous en sommes encore loin la
consultation des groupes parlementaires
en amont de la présentation du texte au
sein des comptes du Ségur n'a pas été
l'exercice de coconstruction attendu il
faudra faire bien mieux pour sortir de
l'impass dans laquelle vous êtes
vous-même placé et qui vous conduit à
user du 20e 493 un triste record je le
dis d'autant plus facilement que notre
groupe a toujours été et demeure ouvert
à la discussion notre opposition n'est
pas sourde et nous sommes prêts à faire
des compromis pourvu qu'il bénéficie à
nos concitoyens dans l'intérêt général
c'est c'est la raison aussi pour
laquelle nous maintiendrons l'attitude
qui a été la nôre depuis le début de ce
cycle nous ne voterons pas cette motion
de censure non pas car nous soutenons ce
projet de loi ni ce gouvernement
mais car nous avons obtenu deux
engagements de votre part celui de ne
pas recourir à une panction arbitraire
des caisses des retraites
complémentaires pour financer le régime
général et de ne pas mettre en œuvre
votre plan d'augmenter les franchises
médicales même si votre ministre Bruno
Le Maire l'a encore réitéré il n'y a pas
si longtemps pour le reste nous
continuons de dénoncer un projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
insuffisant pour répondre aux défis
présents et avenir nous dénonçons un
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale basé sur des économies non pas
que nous critiqu le fait de rechercher à
équilibrer le budget des comptes sociaux
particulièrement après la crise
sanitaire qui les a fragilisé mais
reconnaissant que ces économies se font
là où il n'en faudrait pas souscouvert
d'un renforcement des modalités de lutte
contre la fraude vous procédez à un
affaiblissement des droits des assurés
sociaux c'est le cas de la limitation
des arrêts de travail par
téléconsultation c'est le cas également
de la possibilité de mettre fin aux
arrêts de travail sur la base d'un
rapport rendu par le médecin diligenté
par l'employeur vous prenez le risque
d'affaiblir un peu plus l'accès aux
soins et ce à l'heure même que la
désertification médicale s'accélère dans
nos territoires que les services
d'urgence ferment et que les médecins à
la retraite sont de plus en plus
nombreux en l'absence de mesures
d'ampleur de la part du gouvernement les
initiatives parlementaires s'accumulent
la loi ris ou encore la loi Valtou dont
on ne sait pas encore l'issue rien dans
ce texte ne semble prendre la mesure de
ce phénomène préoccupation majeure de
nos concitoyens nous dénonçons aussi un
pfss insuffisant pour faire face à
l'inflation et aux besoins de nos
établissements de santé les fédérations
hospitalières sont unanimes qu'importe
le secteur la hausse de l'ONDAM ne
suffira pas à faire face à l'inflation
qui impacte aussi bien les coûts de
fonctionnement que les coûts
d'investissement ni même à couvrir les
revalorisations salariales il manquera
au BAMO 2 milliards d'euros en 2024 en
outreem et en Corse particulièrement
nous avons nous avons alerté sur la
faiblesse des coefficients géographiques
qui stinguent depuis de nombreuses
années il s'agit pourtant du levier
principal permettant de rattraper les
retards structurels mais égal ement de
compenser les surcouts et les effets de
seuil liés à l'insularité à
l'éloignement vous vous disiez ouvert à
la discussion sur ce point elles nont
malheureusement pas abouti à une
revalorisation de ces derniers nous
dénonçons enfin un pfss insuffisant pour
répondre aux besoins de nos aînés et à
dotter la branche autonomie de moyens
humains et financiers à la hauteur notre
déception est immense face à l'absence
de ressources nouvelles le transfert
d'une faction de la CSG à la CNSA pour
2024 ne représentera que 2,6 milliards
d'euros nous appelons à la mise en place
d'une contribution spécifique via une
augmentation de la CSG sur le capital ou
bien une contribution sur les grandes
dotations et succession par exemple et
j'insiste aussi sur les métiers mon
collègue Laurent paniifou n'a cessé de
vous questionner combien de postes ont
effectivement été créés sur le budget en
2023 3000 étent budgetés pour 2024 vous
annonciez 6000 ETP soit à peine un par
établissement nous voyons que chaque
jour que votre promesse de recruter
50000 postes d'ici 2027 ne cesse de
reculer ce serait un échec considé ble
il est encore temps d'y remédier vous
vous êtes engagé à faire adopter la loi
programmation d'une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle sur le grand âge l'an
prochain notre groupe qui a défendu avec
d'autres cet événement sera évidemment
au rendez-vous pour la coconstruire mais
attention à ne pas créer de nouvelles
déceptions notre système de protection
sociale mérite mieux que de simples
économies il a besoin de ressources
nouvelles et pérennes des ressources
pérennes pour mettre en uvre une
politique de prévention efficace pour
garantir un accès aux soins partout et
pour tous pour bâtir un vrai système de
soin psychiatrique et une politique de
santé mentale solide des ressources
nouvelles pour financer une branche
autonomie pour assurer nos retraites
actuelles et futures pour consolider une
branche famille dont il n'a été que très
peu question dans ce texte nous nous
appelons à une réflexion d'ampleur sur
l'avenir de nos comptes sociaux notre
groupe avait fait plusieurs propositions
en 20 l'idée de renoncer aux exonétion
de cotisation pour les salaires
supérieurs à 2,5 SMIC était pourtant
partagé par une majorité dans cet
hémicycle et on le sait son intérêt sur
l'emploi n'est que faible par contre son
coût est élevé à 1,6 milliard d'euros
pour soutenir l'emploi vous avez le
choix plus que contestable en
fragilisant les plus fragiles après le
durcissement des règles d'indemnisation
du chômage après la conditionnalité du
RSA jusqu'où irriez-vous Bruno Le Maire
autoproclamé nouveau ministre du Travail
souhaite désormais réduire la durée des
droits du chômage pour les seigneurs
réduire le délai de recours des salariés
contre un licenciement ou encore
l'utilisation des ruptures
conventionnelles pourquoi l'objectif du
plein emploi ne de devit se faire qu'au
détriment des droits des salariés sans
jamais demander un quelconque effort aux
employeurs je rappellerai que toutes ces
annonces sont faites alors même que les
partenaires sociaux doivent négocier un
accord sur l'emploi des seigneurs madame
la Première ministre ne refaites pas
l'erreur que vous avez faite sur la
réforme des retraites n'enjambz pas le
dialogue social après avoir contourné le
dialogue parlementaire madame la
Première ministre é du 493 c'est votre
droit la Constitution vous l'autorise
mais accepter sa sa banalisation c'est
renoncer à ne plus prendre le temps du
débat c'est renoncé à ce que lesé
clivage et les divergences ne
s'expriment plus dans notre Parlement au
risque que la conflictualité se
manifeste avec violence à l'extérieur
jusqu'à un point de nonretour renoncer à
débattre c'est se résigner à cette
violence accepte d'écouter réellement
les oppositions que risquez-vous c'est à
vous de créer les conditions du dialogue
vous pourriez même être surpris
d'aboutir à des consensus utile pour nos
concitoyens 493 motion de censure 493 a
de censure mais attention tant va la
cruchalau qu'à la fin elle se casse et
on parle ici de notre démocratie de
notre santé et de notre crédibilité
devant la société française qui ne cesse
de se fracturer et de s divisé nous
avons des défis à relever madame la
Première ministre mais le refrain 493
motion de censure n'est certainement pas
le bon et il est même mortifère je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
Normand et la parole est à Madame
Caroline yadan pour le groupe
Renaissance et ben voilà je suis là je
suis là
rassurez-vous madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je suis au regret d'annoncer
aux auteurs de la motion de censure dont
nous discutons que même les meilleures
choses ont une fin le terme de la
navette du PLFSS pour
2024 marque en effet celui des sagrés et
des postures insoumises et frontistes au
dépend de notre sécurité
sociale de la préférence nationale
conditionnant les aides sociales au
tomberau de taxes étouffant notre
économie des bidouillages douteux don
d'âme aux invitations massives à la
frautete sociale le rideau tombe
désormais sur l'une de vos mascarades
budgétaire les admirateurs de la
première heure peuvent néanmoins être
rassurés la lecture définitive du projet
de loi de finances leur donnera une
dernière occasion d'être ébloui par vos
meilleurs tours de passe-passe
financiers et par vos plus
impressionnantes acrobaties
idéologiques nul doute que ces derniers
ont également apprécier les épisodes
remarquables que vous leur avez donné à
voir en parallèle des discussions
budgétaires prenons par exemple votre
niche parlementaire LFI laquelle s'est
tenue je vous le rappelle la semaine
dernière et plus particulièrement la
proposition de loi du collègue bonpard
de primabord l'examen d'un 1è texte
aussi
démagogiqueinconséquent ne constituait
pas une intrigue prometteuse mais vous
êtes malgré tout parvenu à en faire un
moment pour le moins pathétique de la
vie
parlementaire mais rendons à César ce
qui lui appartient si l'ordre du jour
vous réserit la tête d'affiche le
rassemblement national vous a
remarquablement donneré la réplique
maîtrisant comme l'on sait à la
perfection son second rôle toujours
fidèle à vos
côté tandis que la majorité
présidentielle s vertuait tant bien que
mal à protéger les consommateurs de vos
idées saugrenu la nuupen la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et
nationaliste a finalement été empêché
inextrémist de mettre en branle sa
terrible machine à créer de l'inflation
que de suspense et quel coup de théâtre
le tout en en préservant un heureux
dénouement pour les Françaises et les
Français vous vous n'avez décidément
aucun talent mais prenons un autre
exemple plus proche de nous la
représentation de votre tragique Hugo
furiosso en commission des lois jeudi
dernier un seul en scène un tantinet
forcé puisque dans ses excès notre
collègue bernalis a avec une violence
effarante empêché les commissaires du
groupe Lyot qui ne demandaient qu'à
contribuer au débat sur le projet de loi
pour contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration de défendre
leurs
amendements une outrance d'autant plus
incompréhensible que ces misérables
gesticulations et cet égosiment aurait
trouvé sa source dans l'incapacité
prétendue de notre collègue à se rendre
en séance afin de voter alors même que
seule une discussion générale était en
cours et qu'aucun vote n'a avait encore
débuté collègues insoumis nous savons
que chez vous la voix d'un seul peut
sans peine couvrir celle de tous les
autres au plutôt de ceux qui auraient le
malheur d'exprimer des opinions
contraire aux siennes sur ce point vous
rejoignez d'ailleurs nos collègues
frontistes qui obéissent chaque jour
sans sourciller au moindre mouvement de
baguette de leur chef collègues nous
sommes ici à l'Assemblée nationale notre
parole est libre et nos
577 voix sont toutes égales c'est de
l'union de ces voix que provient la
force de la légitimité de notre
démocratie et certainement pas de celui
qui crie le plus fort vous en aurez in
cessamment un nouvel exemple cette une
fois cette motion rejetée mais puisque
celle-ci est encore en discussion alors
parlons-en
elle débute par une grave accusation
celle de priver la sécurité sociale de
précieuses recette grave et étonnante
car quelques paragraphes plus loin vous
déplorez les mesures visant à permettre
une récupération optimale des
cotisations des travailleurs
indépendants recourant aux plateformes
numériques or outre le fait qu'elle
abondera les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale elle permettra surtout à ces
travailleurs de bénéficier de l'ensemble
de leurs droits
sociaux dans la même veine
souvenons-nous collectivement de vos
regrets quant à une éventuelle
contribution en provenance des excédents
de recettes généré par la réforme des
retraites au bénéfice de l'
l'agicarco ici encore remplir les
caisses n'est pas une fin en soi mais un
moyen et en l'espèce de revaloriser les
petites pens de retraite du régime
général collègue l'on ne peut que vous
comprendre difficilement lorsque d'une
part vous nous accusez de servir
docilement les intérêts du patronat et
que d'autre part vous applaudissiez des
deux mains certaines de ces décisions
lorsque celles-ci vont dans le sens de
vos dessins politiques la myopie qui
guide vos accusations ne s'arrêteent pas
là puisque vous prétendez que nous
soutenons sans contrepartie les intérêt
de l'industrie pharmaceutique si tentez
que vous en êtes capable je vous invite
à faire preuve de bonne foi pour une
fois ce PLFSS comporte et vous le savez
de nombreuses mesures visant à
responsabiliser les acteurs de ce
secteur et ce dans l'objectif clairement
affiché d'assurer notre souveraineté
sanitaire même constat concernant le
financement de nos hôpitaux si vous êtes
visiblement capable de partager le
constat effectué par le Président de la
République lui-même comment expliquer
que vous ne parveniez pas à saluer le
recul de sa part de la tarification à
l'activité engagée en ce sens par le
texte admettez que cela est quand même
très curieux bis repétita concernant vos
grillefs en lien avec l'attractivité des
métiers de soins et du lien voilà
maintenant plusieurs années que nous que
nous vrons en faveur de la
revalorisation de ses professionnels ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale traduit d'ailleurs les
engagements récemment pris par le
gouvernement notamment pour une
meilleure considération du travail
effectué la nuit et les weekends par les
soignants je passerai rapidement sur la
référence indécente à une fraude sociale
fantasmée dont on sait qu'elle
représente un manque à gagner pour la
sécurité sociale de l'ordre de 17
milliards d'euros un jour sans doute
comprendrez-vous que chaque euro se
trouvant dans une poche où il ne devrait
pas être contribue à priver un autre
assuré des droits auxquels il pourrait
prétendre néanmoins il convient de
souligner que le plus intéressant dans
votre motion n'est pas tant ce qu'elle
contient que ce qu'elle ne contient pas
précisément vous omettez siamment de
mentionner que ce PLFSS que vous
dénoncez contient des mesures de justice
sanitaire et social à l'instar de la
prise en charge des protections
périodiques réutilisablees et des
préservatifs pour les jeunes pour les
jeunes de moins de 26 ans ou encore de
l'extension de l'attribution simplifiée
de la complémentaire santé solidaire aux
bénéficiaires de certains minimas
sociaux vous omettez siamment de
mentionner que ce PLFSS que vous
dénoncez contient des mesures permettant
de renforcer l'axe ACC aux soins à
l'instar de la faculté nouvelle pour les
pharmaciens de délivrer sous condition
certains antibiotiques ou encore la
possibilité pour les services d'accès
aux soins de mettre en place des
réponses spécifiques en matière de de
psychiatrie vous omettez camment de
mentionner que ce PLFSS que vous
dénoncez contient des mesures permettant
de renforcer nos politiques publiques en
faveur des aidents à l'instar de la
création d'un droit rechargeable à
l'allocation journalière du prochédent
ou encore à la prolongation de
l'expérimentation du relayage de longue
durée je vous épargnerai la liste
exhaustive de ces avancées majeures
lesqueles sont légion dans ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour
2024 mais je ne manquerai pas de vous
rappeler que s'opposer à un budget par
posture et entreprendre de censurer
systématiquement le gouvernement qui
vous le présente c'est aussi faire
barrage à ces mesures humaniste ne vous
en déplaise bref cette dernière
prestation dans le cadre du PLFSS est à
hauteur de toutes les autres mention
passable il est temps de se reprendre
d'ici 2027 à peine
d'exclusion la route est manifestement
encore longue et le temps vous est
compté collègues des oppositions
aujourd'hui comme hier et comme demain
pas de raccourci pour vous vous
échouerez à faire chuter le gouvernement
de madame la Première ministre à
laquelle nous réaffirmons notre entier
soutien et notre confiance toujours
renouvelé je vous remercie merci Madame
yad s'il vous plaît dernière orateur de
groupe monsieur Christophe Benz pour le
rassemblement
national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues nous y
voilà à nouveau à nouveau réuni suite au
493 déclenché par la première ministre
sur la lecture définitive du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 après un examen un
examen partiel de ce texte martyrisé par
les multiples 493 et la menace constante
de son déclenchement qui empêche la
sérénité des débats et rend sur le fond
le texte illisible voire
incompréhensible alors même qu'il engage
toute la nation sur notre système de
santé notre solidarité nationale et donc
notre protection et notre cohésion
sociale madame la Première ministre vous
avez dégainé un 20e 493 vendredi dernier
20e passage en fort force 20e mépris de
la représentation nationale et donc 20e
mépris des Français madame la Première
ministre vous avez déclenché ce 493
avant même le débat et le début de la
discussion générale de la dernière
lecture ce n'est pas ntre vous n'avez
même pas voulu écouter une seule seconde
les arguments des groupes politiques qui
composent l'assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée du peuple nous refusons de
nous habituer à ces 493 en bataille
car nous considérons que vous utilisez
abusivement cet outil constitutionnel en
réalité vous le dévoyez de sa vocation
d'origine en plus d'être méprisant pour
la démocratie représentative vous avez
profité des 493 pour retirer des
amendements adoptés en commission ou au
contraire ajouter des dispositions qui
n'ont pas été discuté à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat tout comme l'an
dernier en fait vous avez fait votre
petite pr votre petite cuisine à la
sauce gouvernementale qui laisse aux
Français un goût
amer ce passage en force au mépris des
parlementaires et donc des millions de
Français qui le représentent dissimule
très mal les limites de votre politiqu
vos choix contestables vos erreurs et
votre absence de maîtrise comptable en
matière de
santé pire encore en recourant au
493 vous gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron
vous avez supprimé du PLFSS un
amendement important et de bon sens de
nos sénateurs rassemblement national
pourtant adopté à la Chambre haute cet
amendement visait la possibilité pour
les employeurs et indépendants
ultramarins de conclure avec les
organismes de recouvrement des plans
d'apppurement de leur dettes de
cotisation et de contribution sociale
cette suppression est inacceptable pour
nos compatriotte
d'outrem en recourant au 493 votre
gouvernement a également réintroduit les
disposition prévoyant une contribution
de l'agir Carco au titre de la
solidarité financière du système de
retraite et la compensation intégrale
par l'état des conséquences par le
régime général de l'adossement des
régimes spéciaux fermés ainsi que les
dispositions permettant au gouvernement
de geler les taux de contribution
tarifaire d'acheminement lesquels obèent
le pouvoir d'achat des
Français le gouvernement a supprimé
l'extension aux EPCI de l'exonération
patronale pour l'emploi des aides à
domicile dont bénéficient les centres
intercommunaux d'action sociale
l'exonération de cotisation patronale
pour les entreprises de la filière
frutivinicol ou encore l'extension aux
employeurs publics du dispositif de
réduction de cotisation patronale en
contrepartie de la mise à disposition de
salariés engagé en tant que sapeur
pompier
volontaire autant de mesures que nous
avions soutenu car celle-ci aurait
renforcé nos entreprises nos
collectivités et le pouvoir d'achat des
Français enfin avec avec le 493 vous
avez supprimé la création d'une somme
forfaitaire versée à l'assurance maladie
par les assurés nonorant pas un
rendez-vous médical nous avions déposé
un amendement identique dans le cadre de
la discussion de la PPL
Valtou sur l'accès aux soins afin de
récupérer cet équivalent de 4000
médecins à plein temps perdus chaque
année par ailleurs la revalorisation des
revenus et honoraires de tous les
professionnels de santé par le biais des
discussions conventionnelles tout comme
le prix du médicament semble rester les
variables d'ajustement de votre
incapacité à établir un prévisionnel
juste et
réaliste au-delà de ces suppressions que
nous déplorons c'est-à-dire les mauvais
choix que vous avez fait dans le cadre
de la construction du
PLFSS votre budget est financièrement
déséquilibré tous les paramètres
économiques qui ont permis de bâtir ce
PLFSS sont erronés et totalement
irréalistes par rapport aux données de
croissance et d'inflation retenu par la
BCE tout comme par la majorité des
économistes français en définitive le
budget retenu sur les textes final ne
tient pas compte de la majorité des
observations votées par les
parlementaires députés comme sénateur en
fait vous vous asseyez sur le travail
des parlementaires j'ajoute qu'une
partie des dépenses sont très mal ciblé
les grands enjeux de santé publique dans
les territoires comme le problème de la
désertification médicale accélérer la
Grave dégradation voire la tiersre
mondisation de l'hôpital public et le
recul général des services de santé de
proximité ont été sous-estimés voir
oubliés nous déplorons l'absence de
solutions pertinent adapté durable et
donc efficace à ces crises dont les
Français sont les victimes en résumé
nous n'avons pas confiance dans votre
gouvernement ni dans votre texte qui
manque de crédibilité et aggrave encore
une dérive la financiarisation de la
santé dans ce PLF comme dans le PLF SS
comme dans la plupart de vos textes nous
doutons de votre sincérité mais nous
sommes certains de votre opacité pour
finir il est venu le temps du bilan de
cette séquence budgétaire qui a été
comme l'année dernière chaotique car
vous n'avez ni voulu ni su composer avec
l'opposition à ce sujet se pose une
question de fond madame la Première
ministre combien de temps allez-vous
continuer à gouverner sans la
représentation nationale c'est-à-dire à
gouverner sans les français voire contre
la volonté des Français sur la santé de
nos compatriotes vous êtes aveugle
déconnecté et sans vision et vous êtes
malheureusement encore aux
responsabilités à la tête de la destiné
de la nation française aveugle car à
aucun moment vous ne vous remettez en
cause à aucun moment vous ne remettez en
question votre politique à aucun moment
vous vous n'acceptez de voir la réalité
déconnectter car votre budget est hors
sol il ne correspond pas aux besoins
cruciaux et aux réalités de nos
territoirees il n'est pas à la hauteur
des véritables enjeux de santé de
solidarité de cohésion sociale sans
vision enfin car vous ne fixez aucun cap
à long terme vous gérez péniblement le
budget de la Sécurité sociale à la
petite semaine les députés du
rassemblement national premier groupe
d'opposition à macroni souhaite
sincèrement à la France un gouvernement
qui soit doté à la fois d'une vision
d'un sérieux budgétaire et surtout d'un
pragmatisme politique qui permette
demain d'apporter aux Français des
solutions concrètes et durables aux
difficultés qu'il rencontre au quotidien
et ce depuis trop
longtemps concernant la motion de
censure elle-même maintenant chers
collègues de l'extrême gauche vous aussi
à votre manière vous dévoyez les outils
institutionnels et vous les détournez de
leur mission
d'origine certes comme vous députés de
l'extrême gauche nous rejetions le texte
du PLFSS du gouvernement car il n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux sur le fond
et qui n'est pas acceptable sur la forme
étant donné nous sommes d'accord les 493
à répétition mais nous tenons toujours
au débat car nous espérons faire
entendre raison au gouvernement votre
systématisme a déposé des motions en
tout genre et fatigant
à chaque texte sur tous les textes
quasiment sans exception vous déposez
machinalement une motion de rejet c'est
un réflexe quasi pavlovien qui dénature
l'objet et l'objectif de ces motions
vous les rendez au
final au final inopérante et donc
inefficace l'opposition ce n'est pas ça
l'opposition ce n'est pas une caricature
d'elle-même l'opposition c'est le
pouvoir de rcontrer efficacement les
politiques de la majorité au bénéfice et
au service des
Français qui nous ont fait confiance
pour précisément les défendre et les
protéger des erreurs et des AMS de cette
majorité relative et de ce gouvernement
votre acharnement dans
l'erreur votre volonté de je cite
bordéliser l'Assemblée nationale et
votre sectarisme vicéral vous déshonore
il vous desservve et desservve les
Français avec les motions de rejet syst
à chaque texte et une motion de censure
à chaque 493 vous décrédibilisez et vous
dévalorisez ces mêmes outils politique
que la Constitution confère à
l'opposition à l'image du gouvernement
avec ses 493
frénétiqu les outils politiques de
l'opposition sont pourtant précieux les
utiliser abusivement leur faire perdre
de la valeur et de la force vous avez un
jeu politique tellement lisible et une
stratégie tellement prévisible que votre
posture devient franchement risible
votre jeu stérile il fait à n'en pas
douter le bonheur d'Emmanuel Macron pour
qui vous avez appelé à voter d'ailleurs
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle par ailleurs vous ne
pouvez pas dans le même temps vous
plaindre du manque de débat ici à
l'Assemblée à cause des 493 multiples et
chercheer à les écourter vous-même à
chaque occasion avec vos motions de
rejet sur la plupart des textes que
notre assemblée examine nous sommes
d'accord sur le fond du rejet du texte
du plfsf et le refus des 49 en pagaille
mais nous ne sommes franchement pas
d'accord sur la forme raison pour
laquelle nous ne voterons pas cette
fois-ci votre motion de censure nous
avons nous censuré le gouvernement au
début du tunnel budgétaire mais vous
l'aviez pas voté'z pas voté la seule
motion de censure qui avait une chance
de faire tomber ce gouvernement c'est
pourtant une absolue nécessité
nous ne voulons pas altérer nos chances
de censurer la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron car les Français nous le
demandent nous avons un devoir
d'efficacité dans notre travail
d'opposition en cohérence nous refusons
tous les abus abus du 493 par la
macronie abus des motions systématiques
et en tout genre par l'extrême gauche la
demande du groupe rassemblement national
est simple respecter les institutions
respecter la représentation nationale
respecter la démocratie pour ainsi dire
respecter les Français je vous
remercie merci Monsieur
B s'il vous plaît et la parole est donc
à madame la Première
ministre s'il vous
[Applaudissements]
plaît
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés nous étions le 6
juillet
2022 la session parlementaire avait un
jour et déjà les mêmes députés déposer
une motion de
censure le ton a été donné peu importe
ce que le gouvernement dise ou face peu
importe les résultats obtenus ou les
investissements réalisés peu importe la
demande que nous ont faites les Français
de construire ensemble la censure serait
le cap et le plus petit dénominateur
commun de
l'anupèe bien sûr les motifs et les
styles diffèrent certains agissent avec
une outrance méthodique dans le seul but
de plonger le pays dans
l'instabilité ils espèrent tirer profit
du chos il ne voit pas qu'à l'autre
extrême de l'hémicycle le rassemblement
national les regard garde avec
reconnaissance se discréditer un peu
plus à chacque un jour aux yeux des
Français d'autres je le sais ne
partagent pas cette stratégie du pire
ils sont les prisonniers d'une alliance
baroque qu'il croi être leur seulle
planche de salut
électoral je note dans cette motion le
retour de ceux qui avaient pendant
quelques semaines refuser de mêler leur
signatur à celle de la France insoumise
ils en faisaient un acte de résist
j'ai voulu y voir un acte de cohérence
j'avais
tort il faut dire que le tempo de ce
retour
interroge en fin de semaine dernière un
député insoumis s'en est pris violemment
à plusieurs de ses collègues et dans un
hè débordement je Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
parlé de volonté génocidaire d'Israël
comme quoi certaines ind indignation
sont de courte durée certaines
convictions pè peu face à la peur des
insoumise en réalité cette motion de
censure n'est que la deventure factice
d'une nupesse divisée politiquement
dispersée électoralement écartelé
idéologiquement le constat est simple
vous avez galvaudé les motion de censure
elles ne sont plus que le camouflage
grossier de vos
division mais vous ne dupez personne
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la nup est morte la nup est morte a
déclaré le leader de la France insoumise
jeudi dernier l'ANUP c'est finalement
lui qui en parle le
mieux alors je le dis au députés de la
gauche républicaine n'ayez pas peur
d'assumer vos convictions n'ayez pas
peur de porter une opposition ferme mais
constructive en un mot n'ayez pas peur
de la
liberté en attendant nous voici réunis
pour l'examen de la 28e motion de
censure déposée depuis 18
mois au cours de cette séance comme au
cours des précédentes j'ai entendu les
mêmes orateurs parler dans les mêmes
termes et faire les mêmes
caricatures je vous ai entendu comparer
ces débats à du théâtre à du cinéma j'y
vois un aveu saisissant vous n'y croyez
pas vous-même vous savez que le
gouvernement respecte la lettre et
l'esprit de la Constitution vous savez
que la France a besoin de budget vous
savez que ces 493 s'imposent mais vous
faites semblant vous jouez les indignés
et vous dites regretter le manque de
débat mais vous déposez systématiquement
des motions de rejet qui auraient
précisément pour effet de mettre
immédiatement fin au débat quelle
hypocrisie à chacune de vos
interventions vous rappeler que le
gouvernement n'a pas de majorité absolue
c'est un fait incontestable et personne
ne le
j'y ajoute un autre fait vous n'avez pas
de majorité ni absolue ni relative ni
alternative alors vous nous reprochez
d'avoir employé le 493 pour 6 textes
pour 6 textes depuis juin 2022 il
s'agissait uniquement de texes
financiers cela n'a rien de surprenant
car le 493 a justement été conçu pour
que le pays puisse être gouverné même en
l'absence de majorité absolue au
Parlement qui est notable en réalité et
je parle de la réalité et pas du monde
parallèle dont vous nous parlez Mesdames
et Messieurs les orateurs de laanupes
donc en réalité sur 58 textes
définitivement adoptés 54 soit plus de
90 % l'ont été en forgeant des majorités
avec les groupes
d'opposition ce qui est notable c'est
que les réformes sont votés et les
textes adoptés grâce au dialogue et à la
coconstruction un jour les oppositions
de l'arc républicain accepteront
peut-être même de travailler avec nous
sur les textes budgétaires comme ils le
font sur les autres textes je l'espère
et nous y sommes toujours prêts en
attendant avec la majorité avec mon
gouvernement nous avançons nous prenons
nos
responsabilités mesdames et messieurs
les députés ce PLFSS est un texte de
progrès social nous l'avons enrichi
grâce à la discussion parlementaire
grâce à des amendements de la majorité
comme des oppositions de l'Assemblée
nationale comme du Sénat ce texte ce
sont des investissements massifs et un
budget de 640 milliards d'euros pour
notre sécurité sociale ce texte ce sont
des avancées concrètes attendues c'est
une hausse des dépenses d'assurance
maladie supérieure à l'inflation pour
continuer à moderniser notre système de
santé et mieux rémunérer les soignants
c'est le renforcement de la politique de
prévention et un meilleur accès au
médicaments du quotidien ce sont des
mesures fortes pour lutter contre la
fraude sociale ce sont 6000 postes
supplémentaires en épad créé l'année
prochaine ce sont 7000 nouvelles
solutions d'accompagnement pour les
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
une amélioration de la retraite des
indépendants ce sont des places
d'accueil supplémentaires pour les
jeunes enfants et des rémunérations en
hausse pour les femmes et les hommes de
la petite enfance pouvons-nous privé les
Français la réponse est non avec alors
avec la majorité et avec mon
gouvernement nous agissons et avec ce
PLFSS je suis fier de défendre un texte
qui enrichit et consolide notre modèle
social je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre la discussion est close je vais
maintenant mettre au voix la motion de
censure déposée par Madame Mathilde
Panau monsieur André chassen madame Cyel
Chatelin monsieur Boris Vallot et 143 de
leurs collègues le scrutin est annoncé
anoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle que seul les
députés favorables à la motion de
censure participent au scrutin et que le
vote se déroule dans les salle voisine
de l'hémicycle le scrutin va donc être
ouvert pour 20 minutes il sera clos à
12h31 la séance est
suspendue la séance est
reprise voici le résultat du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure soit la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption
108 la majorité requise n'étant pas
atteinte la motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée en conséquence le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2024 est considéré comme adopté en
lecture
définitive prochaine séance lundi
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui à 15h
proposition de résolution visant à
défendre les démocraties face aux
multiples menaces et tentatives de
déstabilisation proposition de loi
visant à adapter le droit de la
responsab civile au enjeux actuels
proposition de loi relative au
contentieux du stationnement payant
proposition de loi Visante à lutter
contre les discrimination par la
pratique de testes individuels et
statistiques proposition de loi visant à
visant à remédier au déséquilibre du
marché locatif en zone tendue et
proposition de loi visant à soutenir
l'engagement bénévole et à simplifier la
vie associative la séance est
levée